cuáles de los siguientes números reales
son irracionales bueno y racional quiere
decir que no es racional o sea que no se
puede expresar como la razón de los
números enteros en este primer caso a
raíz de 8 entre 2 si tenemos la raíz
cuadrada de un número que no sea un
cuadrado perfecto va a ser irracional y
si tomamos ese número irracional y lo
multiplicamos o lo dividimos pues va a
seguir siendo irracional así que este es
irracional el siguiente pi pi 3.14 15
1965 y así continúa por siempre sin
repetirse nunca y también es irracional
5.0 lo puedo representar como 5 entre 1
así que 5 es racional no es racional
punto 325 pues es lo mismo que esto es
lo mismo que 325 entre 1000 que es una
razón es racional no es irracional 7.77
que sigue por siempre y que sabemos que
sigue por siempre porque tenemos estos
puntos suspensivos o también lo podemos
expresar como ésta rayita encima del
número que se repite hasta el infinito
puede representarse como la razón
números enteros bueno si yo divido 1
entre 3 va a ser igual a 0.3 333 que se
va a repetir creo que también podemos
hacer esto con este 7.7 infinito no lo
voy a resolver aquí pero si puedo
decirles que este es un número racional
el último 8 enteros y un medio es lo
mismo que tener 8 por 216 medios más un
medio 17 medios que también es una
expresión nacional aquí está la razón
entre estos dos números enteros por lo
que los únicos irracionales son estos
dos números de acá